das post logistikzentrum im
niederösterreichischen hagenbrunn ist
vergangene woche in die medialen
schlagzeilen geraten weil nahezu mit
einem schlag die gesamte belegschaft von
rund 400 mitarbeiterinnen corona bedingt
nach hause geschickt werden musste und
das zoom erdenklich schlechtesten
zeitpunkt hat man bei der
österreichischen post zurzeit so etwas
wie weihnachtsgeschäft wir haben jedes
jahr zwei heiße wochen das ist die
letzte im november und die erste
dezemberwoche in der das paketvolumen
sprungartig nach oben geht in der
größenordnung von ca 30 prozent diese
situation haben wir nunmehr durch corona
seit acht wochen hinzu kommt dass einige
paketzusteller mit der derzeitigen menge
an paketen selber probleme haben und
einige zustelldienste haben inzwischen
auch probleme und all diese pakete
landen bei uns das heißt wir haben seit
acht wochen einen mengenzuwachs von 50
prozent und zu diesem zeitpunkt fällt
corner bedingt fast die ganze
belegschaft aus wir haben dann aber in
der letzten woche hier eine häufung von
positiven testergebnissen gesehen
eine häufung die uns sorgen bereitet hat
und auf empfehlung der
gesundheitsbehörden noch nicht auf
anordnung auf die empfehlung die gesamte
mannschaft einmal auszutauschen und 14
tage lang das stammpersonal in
quarantäne zu schicken
auf diese empfehlung hin haben wir uns
gefragt wie wir das umsetzen können und
sind dann auf eine lösung gekommen und
haben uns gedacht die einzige gruppe die
das in österreich kann oder die einzige
organisation die etwas in österreich
kamen ist das österreichische bundesheer
und das hat prompt reagiert so war es
auch dieses mal notwendig ist in
zusammenhang mit dem corona virus im
poster logistikzentrum die notwendigkeit
entstanden ist zum einsatz zu kommen
haben wir das auf schnellstmögliche
nahezu die gesamte belegschaft im
logistikzentrum besteht nun aus 397
bediensteten des österreichischen
bundesheeres die von einem tag auf
anderen die arbeit übernommen haben
notwendige schritt war dass unsere
spezialistinnen und spezialisten des atc
abwehrzentrums korneuburg schon am
wochenende eben die räumlichkeiten des
post logistik zentrums desinfiziert
haben um eben hier auch eine ansteckung
vor ort zu verhinderte einsatz des
bundesheeres war in diesem fall
alternativlos gerade in dieser
herausfordernden zeit mit home office
und quarantäne sind die
österreicherinnen und österreicher ja
noch mehr auf pakete angewiesen als
sonst die krise ist eben noch nicht
vorbei die österreichische post ist ein
system relevanter bereich für die
österreicherinnen und österreicher es
ist mir ein bedürfnis mich zu bedanken
der ein soldatinnen soldaten
zivilbediensteten für ihre
einsatzbereitschaft zum schutz der
österreicherinnen und österreicher